in the book there's a conversation
around design with companies like Apple
we know design or where they're going
with design
what about design for you in your films
in television what is what does
Bruckheimer design well you know what it
is it's not radio it's film you look at
it it's got to look good so we've put a
lot of time and energy into making
things really look interesting and
unusual we always try to put something a
little special a little different in
what we do so that's that's really
important to us in terms of where the
movie business is going obviously you
had a long run with Disney and now
you've got this new first look deal with
Paramount and you've talked about you
know where Disney is focused on its
movies and where you're focused on your
movie is Disney obviously doing a lot of
superhero movies they're not the only
studio doing that right now is there
going to be a superhero fatigue at some
point I don't know I you know I just saw
that the latest Captain America I
thought it was great you know loved
loved being in the theater with
everybody no place is full everybody's
cheering and laughing and it's a great
experience it's but it's what movies are
all about it's the reason you leave your
living room or your kitchen or your den
is to go and see big movies and or small
movies that are effective you know as
long as we make really interesting
movies people always leave their house
the first film that you highlighted as
part of this this new deal with
Paramount was that you're working on
another Beverly Hills Cop right what can
you tell us about it where things are
right now well we're in the process of
getting the script finished and you know
Paramount's very excited about making
Eddie's excited Brett Ratner is excited
about doing it so I think we're moving
forward I think hopefully we'll start
and summer beginning of fall and get
rolling on it you know I'm gonna take
Eddie back to Detroit he's gonna be in
Beverly Hills particularly so we're
gonna have some fun with him and he's
really excited about doing it and the
other film that everyone has been
talking about is the next Top Gun which
I could say you've been working on it
but you really would I mean this is a
long process for you and for Tom Cruise
and you made some headlines recently
sort of setting the stage of cruise
versus the drones can you sort of
elaborate a little bit on well you know
technology's changed obviously since we
need to
one so I think we're gonna take
advantage of what the world is like
today you know with the drones really
kind of taking over in a lot of our wars
but you know is the pilot obsolete is
are those guys are getting those those
those jet jockeys or they're are they
gone from now no I don't think so I
think they're gonna be around for quite
a while because you still have to make
quick decisions and the pilot you want
to make quick decisions so we're gonna
hopefully highlight both worlds what's
the what's the timing on that one what
should we think in terms of when we
might see that in theaters well we've
been working on for over 30 years so
yeah I wish I could tell you it's good
to take us to get there but you know
it's it's a lot of fun working with Tom
and unfortunately Tony Scott who really
came up with the idea I just told you
passed away and and that's very sad for
us I believe David Ellison is a
financing partner through his skydance
the Ellison family a lot of people talk
about them Larry Ellison runs Oracle
David's in the movie business Megan's
getting a lot of attention during the
award season recently what can you tell
us about David Ellison
he's a pilot so that helps us a lot let
me tell you he loves flying and he's
very excited about this and David's got
great taste you know the movies and he's
made have been very successful he
continues to make success successful
movies he's you know he's really
understands the business as as better
than anybody before a guy so young to
understand the deals to understand what
actors work what directors work what
writers work he's really done his
homework and I'm very proud of what he
brings to the project despite the fact
that you have this new deal of paramount
you still have ties to Disney and there
are projects that you're involved with
through the Disney pirates the Caribbean
the the latest installment is one that
people continue to ask questions about
what what what's the latest with number
five we're working on it it's it's
hopefully moving forward Johnny's
excited about it obviously Disney is
we're excited about it so hopefully
we'll get that going this fall or
lines are proper is there a is there a
fifth and a sixth does that you know
everybody loves to talk about these
movies online we make a one at a time
words so Johnny will be back will will
Keith Richards be back just out of
curiosity I hope so we'd love to have
him back so we'll see you have had huge
success in film you've had huge success
in television we could go through it
it's a long list
but obviously CSI is on that list a lot
of people are talking about this as the
golden age of television financially for
you what does that mean is there
literally a pile of gold I mean it has
has this been the most financially
successful period for you because of all
of the stories storylines tied to TV
right now well you know it's been great
for me and you know CSI and all the
shows we put on here they're still
running even though they not might not
be on a network there on on cable
channels and all around but you know
what is what the reason they call it the
Golden Age is because the work is so
good I mean you look at what the other
channels are or networks HBO Showtime
CBS NBC ABC there's so many outlets are
so many ways to show your work and the
work is brilliant Netflix you know some
of the series they have on there they're
amazing stories that are telling with
great actors so our business as far as
television is exploding for an actor or
producer or director there's so many
outlets to make to make little films
whether they're 30 seconds 30 minute
films or 42 minute or you know sometimes
they have these big epics that go on for
three hours it's fantastic for us so
does that mean working with Netflix
partnering Netflix on original shows or
even movies that's something you've been
thinking about absolutely we've talked
to about some things that unfortunately
haven't kind of clicked yet but
hopefully we will in terms of a show
like CSI how long can that show stay on
the air I mean it seems like probably a
long time still it's going on his 15th
season we wouldn't be on 15 years if not
the writing was great and the active
it's great of course we have wonderful
directors who are here and direct our
actors and take those words and make me
come alive we're about to do a spin-off
or hopefully a spin-off of CSI about the
darknet CSI cyber so we're working on
that right
now you know it's all about entertaining
audiences that's what we do so I'm on
that point about the CSI spin-off I mean
you seem quite interested these days in
how technology is influencing society
and ultimately bringing that to the
smaller the big screen then absolutely
you know there's so many things have
changed since I first started making CSI
you know 15 years ago it's a long time
so you can just imagine I mean I don't
know if we had cellphones 15 years ago
but you know things change some people
might not know you got you start in
advertising right so you know how to
tell a story in 30 seconds a lot of
people in Hollywood are experimenting
more with short form video is that
something that you're thinking a lot
about no we haven't we haven't quite
captured that one yet we're still doing
our long form but I think it's a great
great way for young talent to show their
wares where they're on YouTube or other
places to make these little short movies
whether they're three minutes or 10
minutes or whatever they are because we
know to someone they're really good